oh good evening everybody and welcome to
this planning hearing this evening just
a cup of House Rules and if you have a
mobile phone can you please either
switch it off button silence Thank You
pinyin and that may ask during the
hearing I know it's very tempting but I
would ask the people in the audience
there not to interrupt or shout out
during the during the hearing I know
it's tempting but if you could not
please thank you very much and I'd like
to ask people on the panel here to
introduce themselves Thank You chairman
lists of Oscar committee services rocks
chambers legal services I'm Richard
Gardner I'm the Planning Manager for
tonight's meeting and my role is to
provide impartial advice to clarify any
planning issues that arise and to assist
members decision taking I'm bound by the
Royal Town Planning Institute code of
Professional Conduct and planning
committee members are not bound by
advice and officers or by their
recommendations Louise Casey planning
officer John Glen didn't worship county
council highways judge Hobart planner
not coins Senior Planner thank you very
much here's Emily apologies for absence
yes chairman cuts the cuts the crumple
with uncut Stix is substituting and are
there any disclosures of interest
once the panel
the counselor candles no specific
disclosure of interest but I'm just
going to say mr. chairman for say for
clarification I will be if necessary far
into the planning application on this
machine on this here if there's
something I need to pick up on time
fertile officers during the presentation
will do the points of clarification
Thank You councillor kettle thank you
thank you very much
Frank's have no disclosures of interest
but the minutes of the last meeting have
the Hat the panel read the last minutes
of me so you're happy for me to sign
this yes I will sign at the end of the
meeting we don't mind all right then we
will go on to our first application that
is application number 19 oblique zero
zero one three and I'll oblique for land
off Bambi Road peloton priors and you'll
find this on page seven to twenty on the
on the agenda and Louise thank you
chairman the application up for members
is seeking filing permission for the
construction of a detached three-bedroom
dwelling house the application site
identified by the black dot is situated
in the village of phillotson priors the
application site is outlined here in red
and the site comprises a vacant plot of
land situated amongst existing
residential dwellings we've got an
aerial photo here which demonstrates the
relationship between the site and the
nearby surrounding pattern of
development home stalls meadow is here
to the west we've got you tree houses of
the east and we've got for a cows here
to the south is the applications so here
we've got the proposed site layout also
showing the creation of a new access
onto the Boundary Road as well as
parking for two vehicles on the driveway
the site is around three hundred square
meters and the dwell in itself would
cover about roughly 25% of
area so now tie into the proposed floor
plans it's worth noting the dwelling
would occupy a ground floor floor
footprint of around 75 square meters
first law being slight slightly smaller
covering around 61 square meters and
here we've got the proposed elevations
of the dwelling as you can see in the
image here the dwelling would be
constructed of brick featuring some
stonework beneath a clay tile roof so
moving on to some images of the
application site here we've got a view
looking towards the front of the site
taken from the bumper erode brick house
is situated directly behind the
application site here here we've got
views just looking into the site here
some neighboring dwellings behind I've
got the map here shows where the photos
taken from and here we've got views of
the street scene Bambury Road sorry
that's not right so the photo here was
taken yes sorry photos from the streets
in a family road looking towards the
east and we've got the hedgerow here of
the neighboring new tree house the yew
tree house just behind this photo taken
from the same position however planning
to the west
you've got number one home stalls meadow
here central in the photo and this slide
here just shows some images of the
neighboring dwelling so ye tree house
here top left home stalls meadow number
one top right brick house for an
elevation bottom left and this is Gables
end which is just opposite the site on
the other side of the boundary road so
in order to achieve the right-hand
visibility splay the hedgerow along the
boundary of you treehouse will require
some cutting back the hedge at present
as you can see here at least hedge just
here is already overhang in the highway
verge so the photo taken has been it was
taken from the position stood that the
proposed access to point four meters
back from the edge of the highway it's
considered to help illustrate how much
as a neighbor and hedge will need to be
removed in order to achieve the right
hand this play it's been confirmed by
watcher county council highways
that the visibility space with the
proposed axis fall entirely within
adopted highways and so therefore any
works that cutback the heard ray can be
undertaken this next slide here as well
helps demonstrate this further so you've
got the red line here shown on the
topographical survey which is the full
right hand visibility splay as you can
see only this small section of the hedge
here above the red line will need to be
cut back so to conclude the principle of
a single dwelling-house is accepted on
this site because it falls within the
physical confines of peloton priors
furthermore site-specific issues
regarding safe visibility good design
and maintaining neighbors immunity
levels are all acceptable it's therefore
recommended chairman that planning
permission is granted as set out in the
report and there are no updates Thank
You Louise
we have our first speaker it's a
counselor
Ian Green or from Buddhism prize post
counsel as an object
good evening mr. crenell and he had
three minutes Thank You Fulton promised
Parish Council object this application
the area of land had been left with no
access to overgrow since home stalls
meadow was built it had become a home
for wildlife along with a natural
barrier to the noise and light from the
a for two to four the surrounding
properties the main hedge was around six
meters high and over a meter thick
before it was roughly cleared and a
field gate installed in a different
location to the proposed access for this
development this was a major shock to us
as there was absolutely no communication
between the developer and the parish
council we believe this clearance is
contrary to policy cs5 on cs6 which
seeks to protect and enhance the
landscape the current planning
application remove the detached garage
and may change the main building but we
maintain the size and design of the
property is still too large and
overbearing for the size and shape of
the plot this proposal only just meets
the extending your home minimum
requirements so it appears to be what is
the largest property that can be
shoehorned into the site its height and
mass will affect neighboring properties
contrary to policy cs10 we've seeks to
minimize the impact it will affect the
private residential amenity of existing
properties bordering the site and those
on the opposite side of the a4 - -
through daylight and privacy as these
positions on higher ground to those on
kid was Lane the two parking spaces are
on the boundary of the rear garden and
seating area of yew tree house so
headlights will shine directly into
their dining room or exhaust fumes
contaminate their air the availability
of the visibility splay is a major
failing County highways say the hedge
could be trimmed back as it is within
adopted highway land for this
contradicts an email to the Parish
Council in 2015 when the County Council
stated in writing the head
was the responsibility of you treehouse
we want you to refuse this application
as his position and impact on existing
properties makes it unsuitable for
development however should you be
mindful to approve the application the
Parish Council note the 19 conditions
recommended but there are more we feel
should be added and then we would expect
a call condition to be robust and
enforced as this development will affect
people's lives thank you Thank You
councillor F any questions for council
green oh yeah
councillor fielding regard to their goes
against the thing the visual aspect the
woodland
or what is the thing that you're
actually querying on the on that the
officers got the picture we've used in
the last two applications but that hedge
was a massive overgrown sighting out
wildlife in there of birds though there
are newts about there's all sorts in
there and with no correspondence
it was just hacked jolly as a parish
council you've got the problem with
regards to the hedge of almost over
growing the footpath and that should
have been cut back by the by the owner
who planted the trees anyway
the footpath at that point actually
diverts inwards a little bit and then
joins a brick wall for number one home
stores meadow you can't actually see it
from that plan so that hedgerow was
actually further back
it's the hedgerow a blue tree house that
comes forward a nutrient house is on the
right-hand side another image yes
Celso care
quite critical to this is the ownership
of the hedge have you discussed or has
the owner of you tree harvests being
that that got any evidence suggests that
the hedge belongs to them rather than
the kind of counsel you'll be hearing
from the owner of you treehouse up
shortly
an email from Jeff Morris they can't
cancel highways locality officer dated
11 to 10 2015 however while there is
some growth emanating from the highway
verge here whilst I want to remove as
part of a longer-term solution I would
think jollity of the overgrowth is in my
opinion as result the original headline
being allowed to go out to control over
therefore contact the owners of you tree
house who are responsible for the Aged
the question that they deal with the
matter and maintain it in a suitable
condition that does not impact the
highway what the county council did they
came and cut back at a certain amount of
age and said that was our boundary and
then they contacted you tree house to
say over to you now question so when
they cut it back to the boundary does
call you or the belief that in order to
achieve those visual displays further
cut that will be required in our opinion
definitely on one of the photos you
could see a trellis yeah where that
trellises it would have to come right
back to there
councillor fielding the sautée askance
Laban's was about to make a comment if
that is the trellis is that on the
actual boundary of the is there a fence
going along the other side of it that D
marks or marks the boundary of new tree
house that is in filling the other hedge
with new tree house horse approaches the
same time package there and that is what
borders you tree house to their dining
room and their patio area Council
bouncer any more questions for counselor
thanks so much thank you
I'm now next speakers mr. mark Linton
has an objection
I think they press to the middle that's
it thanks mister you've got three
minutes thank you
good evening I actually am the occupant
of you tree house so anybody's got any
questions about the fence and hedging
whatever I'm sitting here really on
behalf of ourselves and the local
residents and it's still our considered
opinion that the proposal of the
3-bedroom house is sort of the following
reasons should be for the following
reasons
dismissed the house is the size of the
house is disproportionate to the size of
the land available
nothing can mitigate for the loss of
privacy to the neighboring properties
there will be issues with vehicles
accessing the site not being able to
turn around within the site and leave in
a forward direction which i think is a
prerequisite of the Highways Authority
onto the a42
however the main issue here is one of
public safety I think somewhere in core
strategy it is lay down and I don't know
what if it's cs65 ten nine whatever but
it does the state that an application
must prove to be safe
well we can't see how this proposal can
be classified as safe the proposed
access leads directly onto the a 42 a
main a road at the eastern edge of the
village the legal speed limit reduces to
30 mph on the eastern edge highways
legislation I believe states that in an
instance such as this there must be
and available 17 meter visibilities play
and this can only be achieved by cutting
back my hedge 87 so they can achieve the
70 meter
visibility's play first point I'd like
to say is where ey is my right not to
have had to cut back any less than the
applicants wish to have it cut back to
gain what they want but I digress
however the 30 mile-an-hour
legal limit is not a true reflection and
a large proportion of vehicles travel
well in excess of this legal limit this
is a fact and it can be seen in the 2011
survey carried out by the highway that
Corey's Authority themselves I have a
copy here in that survey it was evident
some vehicles were recorded at traveling
between 56 and up to 60 miles an hour
the community speed watch speed watched
carried out by bulletin also clock
vehicles up to 67 miles an hour I'd like
to know what the required visibly
display is for those speeds and I would
suggest it's a significant increase on
70 meters I realized the committee has
to be led by advice from other bodies
but in this instance the severity of
severity of the safety issue cannot be
overlooked and sure--we surely highways
must be asked to reevaluate their
decision in not objecting to this
proposed access someone is going to be
seriously injured or killed if this
proposal is approved thank you very much
almost spot-on thank you very much
indeed
thank you
I know it's any questions councillor
Dixon good evening we don't know from
these diagrams where the access from
your own property is is is it directly
onto the Boundary Road or is it onto a
side road and then the property on my
access is offer lane which is not
directly onto the a42 Thank You
councillor Fielding can we go back to
the other plan from that drawing looks
as if the green in front of this
proposed new house is the boundary which
on the other side of which is highways
surely if you take that boundary along
those hedges are encroaching on two
highways am I right or I wrong I would
say what I'd like to say is that the
hedge does not overhang the public
right-of-way ie the footpath now I
believe that there is a strip of land
and I'm not quite sure how what it is
but maybe one and a half metres from the
edge of the footpath that is classified
as highways land and in which case are
hedge my hedge do trees house edge would
overhang that highways land but it
doesn't overhang or interfere in any way
with the public right away I've made
sure that
that counselled unit I'm assuming if he
can perhaps show the diagram that there
are other existing houses already having
access onto this a four to two
Susan you happy with that - closer okay
thank you can't counter kettle if we go
back to the site line diagram please
mr. mr. Linton where is your boundary or
I've got a hot new treehouse sorry where
is you treehouses physical boundary in
relation to that red line does it have
any point course that red line
I don't think so right it the line goes
through the hedge but I don't believe
that it would cross over my boundary yes
no no it's not
well I have I for we have a had a fence
installed within the hedge but it was
the only place we could install a fence
to keep out badges and the like we
couldn't put that fence on the other
side or actually within the hedge itself
it had to be done on the house side of
the hedge but the as far as I understand
it the boundary of our property is a
meter or so the other side of all the
roots of the existing hedge which is
some 80 hundred years old the hedge is
in within the boundary of our property
the roots are therefore it makes it our
hedge obviously there are parts of the
hedge that then will have grown out and
overhang a stretch of the Highways lamp
if the highways land is one and a half
metres is it common what we said
from there to the carrot right
my big question officers shortly
counselor Bart am i right in saying that
the visibility's plays of this
application on your land and only your
land
I'm sorry I didn't quite understand that
the visibility's play the 70 meter
visibility splay can only be achieved by
cutting back the hedge that is in the
possession of my house
Thank You mr. Linton I think one knows
one another representative of other
residents the village if we look at the
how many houses along that road in the
stretch that were some in that picture
have an access that goes straight out
onto the 42 yeah but their existing
properties well there's a disabled
gentleman that lives opposite who has
access but he doesn't even have a car
doesn't leave the house in which
direction
well there's access to home stores
meadow which is further down to the left
and there just a place to be what
there's one further one to the left of
that more questions thank you thank you
salute and thank you very much indeed
and we have the the applicant mr. Tim no
sorry the agents I should say mr. Tim
Farley thanks respond you've got six
minutes mr. chairman members thank you
for the opportunity to speak today in
support of this application sorry to
snow when you want us to change you're
treating the slides yep I've got Ward
layering No
as you know this application has been
deferred twice once remember site visits
and wants to allow us to amend the plan
to reflect the highways land ownership
for which the applicant is grateful one
of the reasons that the determination
was deferred for a site visit was
concerned about the edge as we've had a
long discussion on already in front of
Nick you treehouse and the need to
nominally trim the hedge to provide a
satisfactory visibility splay as is
noted in the committee report how his
authorities confirmed that any such
works would be within the land ownership
of the Highways Authority and is this
perfectly lawful as a result of concern
raised at the site visit we've amended
the plan to incorporate the proposed
hedge within the application sites
pulling it back therefore its planting
and maintenance can be controlled by
condition this has resulted in the
parking area and the house being shifted
back by around 1 meter concern has been
raised regarding the loss of the cherry
blossom tree which has got a red line
around it is identified as t5 and it's
been assessed as category you this tree
is dying and beyond remediation works
therefore it presents a risk in the
short term medium term and should be
removed over the applicant would be
happy to replace this with a semi mature
tree at the same species
and would accept a condition in this
regard there has been an objection
alleging that the proposal represents
over development of the site but this is
not borne out by the facts the private
amenity space amounts to 94 square
meters reduced slightly since the house
was repositioned that sort of very good
size by modern standards the distance
separation standards to protect the
immunity and privacy of neighbors remain
satisfied by this amended siting there
is a policy compliant level of parking
proposed and safe and satisfactory
access as confirmed by the latest
consultation response from highways the
block density is around 34 dwellings per
hectare
thanks very much as you can see from
this slide in front of you and this also
shows instances of other homes in the
local area around the same density so
you can see that it's not uncommon
it's a typical plot coverage and it's
actually absolutely standard and has
been for many many years in fact first
trillion per hectare is has for a long
time being considered the absolute
minimum target and until recently it was
adopted policy in the 2006 local plan
review minimum thirty-two dwellings per
hectare so we're on 34 - that's very
similar as detailed in the committee
report the proposal complies with local
and national planning policy and
guidance officers have meticulously
assess other material considerations and
found none to undermine the fundamental
fact that this is sustainable
development in an appropriate location
and there was a presumption in favor of
granting planning permission the last
slide I've provided
after the presentation is a photo of a
small development recently built by the
applicant the designer the proposed
dwelling is quite similar to this but
the reason I wanted to include the image
is to demonstrate the extremely high
quality product that by far exceeds the
standards of typical house builders in
terms of detailing and materials and
specification when built and the
landscaping is established the phrase
dwelling will be a real asset to this
tree seam the applicant has won a number
of awards in South Derbyshire and
Northwest last this year for small
developments they've done like this in
particular the conservation quality
design that they use I've got a few more
minutes I finished my speech but I just
wanted to talk about the edge and the
visibility spray again obviously the
hedge roots are within the neighbors
ownership within you tree house but then
it extends two and a half metres over
the highway land and as with any of our
homes if the neighbor had a hedge
growing two and a half metres over
Ireland then we were perfectly liberty
of cutting it as the highway of
authority would be what they could
require the owner to cut it and build
one and so I just wanted to sort of
confirm we've talked about the trellis
in the photograph and appears to me that
the trellis actually extends into the
highway land by the looks of it because
it's you know three and a half meters
away from the carriageway
so I think that's a bit of a red herring
but the fact is that at the very extent
of the hedge closest to the application
site he'll have to be reduced by about
50 to 60 centimeter and then that take
away to nothing within about two meter
so it's actually a fraction of the hedge
you've got 35 minutes out about 30
seconds okay I guess it is a fraction of
the edge on highway land and they're
perfectly at liberty to say that it can
be trimmed back thank you thank you very
much
have you any questions you know you know
thinking counselor kettle whether you
have one I am thinking just just was
there any attempt to speak with the
Parish Council on this they know
something it's a very small scheme as
far as councillor fielding I see from
from the documentation ecology had no
problem with no objections to net new
tech cetera how have you done it
did you do a survey or there was a to
ecology who did a survey yeah there was
a any college of assessment I think
submitted with the application of such a
long time ago records that committee BRB
it was and no objections
sorry do we have any more questions for
the agent No thank you very much man
thank you
we all have our counselor penny anode on
the wok for the ward member thank you
and you have five minutes
Thank You chair I just address a couple
of points that have been raised so far
counselor do not the access on to the a
four to two from home stores meadow has
better visibility and it's um it's a
small development so it's not a single
property coming out on to there with
regard to the hedge row blocking the
footpath as somebody walks up and down
there many times especially when I was
that canvassing it doesn't in any way
impact on access and I've just been
advised at the trellis that you were
shown was put there in January due to
the head clearing that took place by the
applicant with regards to the site so
that trellis is only been there since
January 2018 so just to clear up a few
of those things can we to members I'm
here to support the parish council and
to ask you to go against the officers
recommendation and to refuse its
application this case is site-specific
and does lie on the busy a four to two
and I'm behind has done that when
members visited the site they noticed
how fast the traffic was the Impella
ttan they've already got the development
of ten properties of ribbon development
going up just a stone's throw from the
application as we speak so they are not
anti development as a village of note is
the lack of engagement no matter how
small the application we need people to
engage with locals and a state in the
NPP F 12 paragraph one to eight early
discussion between applicants the local
planning authority and local community
about the design and style of emerging
schemes is important for clarifying
expectations and reconciling local and
commercial interests applicants should
work closely with those affected by
their proposals could evolve designs
that take account of the views of the
community applications that can
demonstrate early proactive and
effective engagement with the community
should be looked on
more favorably than those that cannot
there has been no engagement at all
whilst acknowledge that change is made
to the application my concerns remain
the same I question whether this truly
complies with the cs9 its lay out an
orientation and not sensitive the
existing build form of note is the loss
of privacy for Gables End which was
actually shown incorrectly on the slide
it's of property rather rough it's a
property on the opposite side of the
road on the corner of kippers Lane where
the properties are of a lower standing
from the upstairs in the proposed
property you will have a direct view
into the Sun lounge of gable end after a
household with a young family this is
simply not acceptable I am concerned
regarding the lack of parking with no
garage and two parking spaces for a
three bed property where all the
visitors go to park surely not on the
dangerous a42 to where speeding goes up
to 67 miles per hour and hopefully not
on home stores meadow remaining with
cars the parking space is proposed will
impact on you tree house with other
headlights or exhaust fumes which simply
again isn't acceptable and goes against
our clean air initiatives which
proposing as a council looking at cs5 we
look to prepare to protect the hedgerows
and this hedge has had a lot of
discussion I'm still unclear as to whose
hedges being cut back and that is a
confusing email from Jeson Jeff Morris
back in 2015 which did advised the local
hedge line was a responsibility of yew
tree house given the lack of
consideration for neighboring properties
the uncertainty regarding the ownership
of the hedge the lack of adequate
parking and the impact of parking
location on new tree house along with
the complete lack of engagement in
regard the local community this
application should be refused this
appears to be in full of the worst kind
I'm pleased that the applicant has won
awards for a high standard product
perhaps communicating the locals could
be added on to their to-do list I wonder
with the people who are planning this
application actually planning to live
there because if they are they have not
engaged with their future community very
well I would ask you as a committee to
share regard for the people of peloton
priors because currently their views and
concerns are not being listened to by
this application you have as a committee
the ability to show regard and listen to
their fears and recognize that they have
a voice when it comes to
the developments within their village
goes across otherwise what's the point
of local representation now one of the
recommendations if this goes through
that the private accounts would like to
be considered is the removal of
permitted development rights to prevent
any further extension of the property
because they do feel it's over over
development of the plot I therefore urge
you to go against the offers
recommendation and refuse this
application which particular are you
referring to the sensitivity yeah
the lack of sensitivity or the
distinctiveness the lack of sensitivity
the existing built form around it where
there's been no engagement with the
neighbors there will be a lack of
privacy there is an overlooking aspect
and with regard to the parking in the
cars so I don't there's any sensitivity
be shown with regards the existing built
form well sorry can I keep going the
houses on the left-hand side
there in the 1990s so basically they're
red bricks similar to what this is going
to be it's not a design it's about how
it's going to impact upon what's already
there there's been no sensitivity
regards to the positioning of this
property so you don't want to take into
account design I haven't mentioned the
impact of design I've said it's how it's
impacting upon the properties are
already there and taking them into
consideration go back to one of the
images shown by the agent that we had a
street scene which was right the way
along the front there not that one keep
going that one that is that purple one
the application that we gave approval to
this year or late last year what's the
name on that property I can't see it
from here
we'll see how that's relevant to this
that may be a question for clarification
with the officers yes it's just
basically that's stuffed into a smaller
area than this one I think you'll recall
I actually objected to that application
for those reasons as well any more
questions for before we go I may have
missed it
have you a neighborhood plan I think
it's there in the stages their
neighborhood plan outs are you with it
Nietzsche say that to you the moment
wouldn't carry a lot of weight okay
sorry Chow I didn't hear that
I said that moment probably wouldn't
carry a lot of weight or what their way
stages at okay thank you
more questions is that a feature of any
other houses the lack of gates it on the
a for to to have gates yeah yeah when
I've been canvassing I've had to open
many gays
I always clears them child they think
thank you all remember right we now have
take your points of clarification with
the officers kelsa fielding we'd like to
get a legal or highways opinion of the
hedge hanging over the highways land
which is that green area light green
area which is the property of the
highways so what exactly is a question
the question is is the hedge that is
hanging over highways land is that the
responsibility of the landowner or the
new developer or highways to cut it back
well it's it's both rarely if we don't
proactively go cutting back every hedge
to be to the boundary and if it's
required which it would be if this was
approved we could serve notice to the
landowner the owner of new tree house
for them to cut back the hedge as far as
we need it to be cut back which is just
that that's required with the
visibility's clay we'd serve that notes
under Section 144 of the highways act
1980 and in which case we could get the
the householder Fieri house to cut that
edge bag alternatively I believe we also
have rights to cut that back ourselves
as as our request didn't land this
highway under common law so we could
also approach it from that way but
generally we we prefer to approaching
through the the proper channels through
the highways act what about the comment
about routes
all the roots the major comment was the
roots were on new trees land but they
were overhanging the highways what is
the - that's the roots part and parcel
with the ownership always that part and
parcel with the key thing to remember is
conditional evans recommending of his
ability splay and to achieve that
visibility display officers have
calculated that you would need to lose
that triangle triangular area of hedge
there mr. glendenning's confirmed that
all of that is within hi white land and
their forts in the control of public
authority and can take place which would
enable that visible display to be matte
now the roots may well go underground
and under there but they wouldn't impact
on the visibility splay the important
thing is in the above-ground element to
the hedge counselor kettle we seem to
have a straight conflict here because
the landowner or view treehouse has said
that his land extends to I think 60 to
70 centimeters beyond the footings of
the hedge and therefore that land is in
his own ownership and I think I'd be
surprised if you could force a landowner
to come back a hinge which stirs which
actually it's in his own vertically is
with his ownership are you saying that
you can actually it require a landowner
trim to trim edge back which is not
overhanging highways land that's not my
understanding of what's been said what's
been said this the natural trees
themselves so praising hedges where the
roots meet the ground is within its
ownership or on the boundary the where
the hedges projected forward is
forbidden highway that's by
understanding and once we can use our
powers under Section 1 5 4 of the
weighs out but he specifically said his
boundaries about sixty centimeters
beyond the hedge ir if you call I
questioned him on that on that twice and
on both occasions he said his boundary
is the far side of the hedge I seem to
remember saying are you on the other
side I've been some of what mr. Linton
said is it's slightly confused it he
because he also said that the the
highway land extends about one and a
half meters beyond the back of the foot
way which is about three and a half
meters the development side of the
carriageway I think the important thing
is that the highway authorities public
body have confirmed that all of the
visibility splays within the control of
the Highway Authority we've no other
evidence tonight in the form of a Land
Registry panel nothing's been submitted
application to dispute that
therefore my recommendation would be to
go with what the highway authority have
said in the light of no other evidence
Thank You chairman my question relates
to the same area I appreciate that
the landowner has a edge planted on his
land it has grown a degree of width some
of that is obviously in towards you tree
house its own some of it is towards the
highway what I appreciate the highway
are able to either cut back to within
its own land anything which is
overhanging his land obviously not back
to where the hedge is planted but
obviously it's first course of action
would be to ask the yew tree house owner
to do that my view is that hedges tend
to grow every year and whilst we have a
developer who wants to put a property
there I don't think it's for their own
use is for some to be sold and you have
a householder there my question again
it's a legal one in truth
is can the householder and force that
sight line if the owner of that hedge
refuses at any time in the future to cut
back those branches which are
overhanging the highway can that
resident end force common-law and cut
that hedge back himself or herself etc
all musty then applied to the County
Council to come back and enforce it
because hedges will grow every year
they'll have to be trimmed back to that
sight line every year highway say I
think it would just be the Highways
Authority that have the power to require
that to be cut back if it overhangs
highway then it's Highway Authority once
that axis is there our maintenance would
reflect the fact that there is an access
so at the moment there's there's no need
to to cut it back any further than it is
because it's not absolutely anyone's
visibility would be the planning
authorities control over that as
recommended and if it grew into a
position where it's presenting a highway
danger we could serve a breach of
condition notice to require it to be
trimmed to the correct level how that it
takes place isn't a matter for that
planning authority it would be a matter
for the owners to source that amongst
themselves but as we've heard tonight
from mr. Gunn dinning it's quite clear
that the highway authority have control
over that which gives us in a
satisfaction to recommend it in the way
we have councillor Barnes helpful I've
got two instances where the highways can
come and cut the head off the land and
on the highway and I can assure you they
rights to the people concerned and they
quickly get it done
figures highways charge about 10 down
more than
because the highway yes I I know that
[Music]
well first on that road do you have any
evidence as to the level of compliance
with the 30 degree limit in posting bras
and whether that is yes as you can see
on the original site plan originally 70
meter visibilities place were in sharing
on their the original space was shown 43
metres which is the standard for 30 mile
an hour zone
according to manual for streets the
application wasn't accompanied by any
speed survey data or anything like that
and so us as the Highway Authority we
asked for the 70 meter visibility
displays which is in accordance with the
design manual for roads and bridges in
in a precautionary and for a
precautionary reason so well above and
beyond 30 miles per hour we don't as a
matter of course carry out speed surveys
us
to determine where they're compliant on
every planning application we filled a
speed set the visibility's place we've
asked for reflect kind of a range of
compliance within that within the
traffic on on the road the one thing I
would kind of clarify is some individual
spot speeds were mentioned by mr. Linton
we wouldn't be looking at the highest
speeds achieved along that road when we
do do a survey we would look at the 85th
percentile speed which is the speed that
only 15% or exceeding and so looking at
kind of individual highest speeds
wouldn't really come into our assessment
counselor cattle processing these things
I think I recall the reverse tables as
to what is the appropriate side distance
or setback record it for certain speeds
and you've mentioned that 40
I think 42 meters will be the would be
the calculus or the required distance
for people complying with 30 miles an
hour if we reverse calculate you're
suggesting 70 what would be the speed at
which you would require a 70 meter
visual spray well it it's beyond the
kind of standard table for manual for
streets so it would be it would be in
excess of 40 miles per hour I couldn't
tell you the exact speed without M
going through the the formula that's
with the money or for sweets we
calculated now if not I've not got the
not got that in front of me to do that
but it's it's above 40 miles per hour in
terms of manual for street standards but
it's based the 70 meters has come from
this iron manual for roads and bridges
and it's it's a kind of most more
stringent more stringent code counselor
fielding they did some time ago have
police speed cameras further out the
street and a number of people got caught
and consequently I've always maintained
30-game through there I'd like to take
this on to the next stage because I
think we've gone far enough and what we
can do and my proposal is that we go
along with what the planning officers
recommend council we have started a
debate yet alright can we just talk
about separation distances which are a
little bit less contentious possibly
you've got a separation distance between
you three house and then you mentioned
has its dining-room window facing this
property and you're going to have
sufficient light because the territory
is cut down is that correct that is
mentioned in the report that the removal
of the cherry tree will allow additional
light to come through but it's not just
relying on the fact that cherry trees
cutting down regardless of cutting down
the cherry tree there would still be
sufficient light into that room it's
just helpful but it's being cut down in
in that regard
and what about the bedroom the upstairs
bedroom
yeah it's concluded in the report that
having conducted an assessment that
would be sufficient light into that room
as well given the separation distance
between the property and you tree house
first floor of the property is not as
doesn't doesn't extend as far west east
sorry it's it's the the build line
finishes about here at first loss it's
been taken back to take into account
that that relationship and of course at
first floor you've got more life anyway
because it's higher up in the building
so it's less overshadowed then are there
any windows on the side facing you tree
house which will be overlooking before
possibly looking into the bedrooms of
there's no side facing windows
overlooking you can see here it's Bank
elevations thank you and what about on
the other side both both side elevations
no no proposed side facing windows right
thank you thank you Kelly Kettle right
can we go to the debate then panel
condition five of the letter from what
kind of council on the side first to the
fifth of nineteen
requires that gates or bearish will not
be erect at the entrance to site for
vehicles there is no mention of that in
the report is there any reason why that
has not been referred to in the report
ends conditions yeah its condition
thirteen on page eighteen
can we go to the debate panel Thank You
councillor fielding
I recommend that this gets approved the
major reason it was being turned on
twice is because of the highways and the
hedgerow we we have been informed both
by highways that it is on that covers
their land the the grass verge they can
cut it back regardless so they could cut
it back even if we didn't give
permission but I recommend we go along
with and therefore I propose that we
accept this Council bonds I thought
everything second that I really cannot
see a reason for refusal Thank You
counselor
councillor kettle I do have problems on
speed on this road it's a road that I
have a normal life crossed many times
coming up from the current of the road
which you will be familiar with
councillor Mills putting on to the main
road at Peterson Prize and traffic comes
around that corner or the other side of
the road incredibly fast and you have to
be quite quick to pull out therefore I
understand that we've got a 70 meter
visibility splay going looking away from
the village but I'm concerned that we
haven't a real understanding of what the
speeds are we've got we've had some
hearsay evidence from the immediate
neighbor and I'm still concerned we've
had a specific comment from the neighbor
that he owns the whole hedge and a strip
of land beyond the hedge now we also
have an email which has been referred to
which mr. Glendenning is not familiar
with I understand that because it's just
four years ago saying that highways have
no responsibility for that hedge so if
that email has been sent from the County
Council we do seem to have a conflict
and I don't think we are clear
at that point mr. Gardner has said mr.
Bern Daniken said repeatedly it's all in
the ownership of the relative is all the
in the ownership of the oven and the
caddy counsel but I'm not actually
convinced that the splinting has
confirmed that because he wasn't quite
sure where the boundary sat so it might
be a prefer the point of clarification
but it is quite important where the red
line of this property is property sits
if it's six and the hedges entirely his
then it would be trust us for the County
Council to go on we'll come to murder we
don't know that this is a clarification
or is it and we interesting part of the
debate and therefore I think we have a
but I have person have a problem with
that
and whether it should be deferred until
we have a clear understanding of exactly
where the boundary sits as to whether
the hedge can or cannot be trimmed back
Pacific can't be trimmed back we have a
problem if it can be trimmed that we
have no problem but we have no
definitive red line on since I
understand it it can be trimmed back the
County Council can enforce the trim back
the County Council of confirms that all
the land required for the visibility
display display is within their control
count the council eviction I was simply
going to point out that the the hedge
may be in the ownership of the owner of
you tree the fact that he over grows the
public highway does not make the part
but over grows the public highway in the
ownership of the County Council he
always remains in the ownership of the
land owner of that hedge it simply means
that the highway authority can trim it
back as required thank you
the whole point of it I'm too personal
I'm I have to say I'm not - I feel
uncomfortable about this application
there's two meters of Batson
I know this particular piece of road I
know the highways of raised no
objections it does come on - very busy
stretch there and it seems to narrow up
with where you've got Kibler Lane just
round back kippers Lane it's quite
narrow and I don't I'm not sure whether
you know that houses are long along
there they do actually come straight
down onto the road it was some Somerset
back quite some way the size the
property I don't feel comfortable with
either anyway we all alone we can we put
this to the vote I was just gonna say
one we'll find out I'm sorry concerned
about the safety and the gateways issue
if that we don't know the it's gonna be
living though or not and that's not a
relevant matter for us to consider but
it is it is always within feasibility
that children will live in this house
children live in many houses and not
having a gateway and I think comforted
on almost and thought the other doesn't
seem to have a gateway it is a fairly
common feature particularly on fastest
roads to have some sort of barrier to
prevent that small people wandering out
onto the road here there is a specific
condition which been put in and thank
you Richard pointing out it is it the
planning out with our planning papers
that this should not be fenced for a
highway safety reason one of other
conditions we should consider is safety
in the planning application and I'm sure
we'll I'm not gonna policy it is there
as to whether that is something which we
should consider whether yes the space
for an adult sort of that is based to
turn around the vehicles in there but in
the long term future should there be an
ability to fence this security so that
there isn't a risk
but actually because Clause 13 or 13 or
14 it's going to prevent any gateway
being put in that thank you I think
that's a matter of parenting really if
you've got an open-plan frontage then
children of a certain age would need to
be supervised in that area
but I suspect most properties that have
that mine included have a French to the
side so that children have a safe area
to area where they would need to be
supervised to avoid running out onto the
road and we digressing slightly on this
and no councillor bars could you switch
your mic off there please Oh unless you
want to say I'm so sorry unless you want
to face it was it proposal and a second
right we have a proposer two grants
application from councillor fielding
than seconded by Councillor Barnes
we'd like to would like to make a vote
on supporting the officers
recommendation those against so it's
carried is granted application is
granted thank you very much
thank you but it the next application is
reference numbers 19 oblique zero one
zero four six oblique ful garish blocks
and within since Wiggins drive lower
Quintin construction of Reid dwellings
and associated works Joe Brooke is the
presenting officer so Joe thank chair
the application site is located in the
physical confines of low in Quincy at
Saint Swithin's Drive as indicated by
the black dot before you the plan before
you've demonstrates the site is located
at the end of st. Stephen's Drive so
nice to work that is st. Stephen's Drive
brought into the case and that has the
application sorry the site used to
previously has a block of 21 garages
that were subsequently demolished in
2017 2018
the site is presently open land with no
buildings planned all development the
surrounding areas defined by a mixture
of different housing types to immediate
west south and east along st. Swithin's
Drive a three-story brick built
apartment blocks beyond the partner
blocks to sofa sang-soo and as drive our
two-story red brick dwellings so just to
clarify further these are three story
apartment blocks and needs us to story
dwellings and we'll show photos further
on to the west of the application Elston
close which is here is defined by
two-story red brick and some mock tudor
dwellings with front and rear gardens
directly to the north as you can see in
the plan the RAS open crunch site the
application is not situated in any
landscape or under law heritage
designations
[Applause]
the developers of employees of free new
red brick dwelling contrasting buret
courses and the concrete interlocking
roof tiles the application would also
see the introduction of ports is the
principal evasion as well as front and
rear Gardens the development is
proposing the step bamboo fire
arrangement as you can see before you
the to dine in Scituate to the east the
prince motivation so these are the two
dwellings will be set the same
three-story high as a flats to media
east and south I'd be outraged street
scene further on while the step bound to
the two and our story dwellings is prose
recited Jason to I also enclose to the
west of the prints revelation so and
this is these two dwellings with the
flats for each story flat situated there
out some clothes is over here before you
is a block plan indicate in how the
layout would look if approved so this is
number 15 Allison closed for the garage
the three-story apartment blocks and
parking situates up front with front and
what with small front and rear guard and
this is a block plan for all means I'll
go into more specific data if you wish
to during officers questions as you can
see this is the site so at the minute
there is no development on the site and
is being closed off that's the
three-story apartment but just there
number 15 Allison close so West there's
a further site of the department blocks
which would be a solid directly adjacent
to the application if plan of missions
full come in and this is an indifferent
this is a street scene of st. Swithin's
Drive says the application starts down
here the massive Hartman blocks and you
see these are the two-story drawings
extenuate along st. if enjoys two main
roads situated at the end this is st.
else enclose so if the development was
approve
the dwelling will be situated here with
a stackpanel Ridgeline and this is the
application site taken from the north so
in the open field Saskia Parton box to
South Austin closed and the FreeStore
blocks adjacent this is the indicative
street scene facing the flats so you can
see the three storage islands will be
situated at the same roof height level
then a step down and then you go on 12th
in close there that's the end
presentation
conclusion the prints for the three
drones is accepted because they fall in
the physical confines of low Clinton and
so Pacific issues regarding good design
highway safety and maintaining neighbors
Amita those are all considered except
for is therefore recommended planning
permission is granted as set out and the
officers report you will note on the
update sheet there are some amendments
furcy worn under counts of theater has
emailed myself stating I support the
comment so we made by counsel Robert
Spooner regarding in this application
also we have received two further
letters of rejection from third parties
raising the following planets iterations
which are listed within the update sheet
also just for clarity the first sentence
with a neighbor and amenities should we
read that there are no overlooking side
facing windows on toast and growth and
also for further clarification the free
side facing apartment windows on to the
east the application error would not
meet the 45 25 degree test Thank You
Jojo we have our first speaker counsel
Robert Spooner for Quintin parish
council objecting
thank you hello counselor Spooner you
have three minutes thank you
it's a Quinton parish council and the
owner of fifteen Elston close to whom I
spoke when the previous application was
made would support the construction of
housing on this brownfield site as an
infill within the proposed built-up area
boundary but with properties that are no
higher than the apex of the roof of
fifteen Elston close the height of all
three houses in the planning application
are just unacceptable though there are
blocks of flats nearby from a Planning
era of long ago where they now to be
proposed they would be opposed Quinton
is not Hong Kong we do not need to
squeeze high-rise properties out of this
small piece of land to two-bedroom
bungalows might be well-received within
those residents in the parish whose use
of stairs is challenging and without to
the poor being built on the braum foot
development not many yards away to then
match the six identified in our housing
needs survey conducted in the past three
months to three-bedroom homes would also
be welcome subject to the height
requirement stated before the site has
been left as an eyesore and it needs
good use you show that one there in fact
the picture named street scene has three
trees to the left of the left hands
similar in width to the proposed
adjacent house frankly I think that's
misleading
I think that's trying to portray
something nicer than it would be the
space does not exist I think for that
I've looked at this site several times
including last Saturday morning and I
cannot imagine three houses there
never mind three plus the huge tree
the core strategy lsv one apportionment
has not been fully quoted when it says
that LS v1 has sort of deliver for
Queens and a hundred and twelve point
five it would be not more than a quarter
four hundred fifty houses when in fact
853 are named in a document fifteen
months ago is already being planned or
being built we request that you refuse
this application any questions to the
councillor counterbalance it's too high
it's there just I actually kept their
matchstick houses I just can't see that
anyone want to buy it but that's nothing
to do with me thank you Thank You
council any cancer careful so can we
just get your housing numbers that was
published 31st for 31st of March 2018
quoted a hundred and I would currently
dispute that I think a little bit
further into this year when another
matter has been resolved I want to talk
about the numbers that are being
apportioned to Quintin but the whole of
LS v1 I'll use the word requirement I
know it's not in concrete is 450 and
that document of 15 months ago says that
all five villages are delivering 853 we
currently have 30 just delivered down at
place called Swithin's wood and
currently under construction but none
yet occupied of 44
on the site called goose lane which was
a loss
remember councillor Barnes comment a
great sad loss of agricultural land this
is a brownfield site we would welcome
some housing on it because something
good has to come of it but not this
development councillor fielding do we do
you know your quota of bungalows and
three-bedroom house this is something
that we could so we're falling back on
memory right now
but on the braunfels development there
are and I know this in fact four
bungalows being developed there are the
various ranges of houses there are three
bedroom and four bedroom houses there
st. Swithin's would deliver some
bungalows at the back and various
different houses the next planning
application is for houses that are more
significant in size further down the
Camden Road there are four houses built
became for sale last September none of
which has been occupied so we already
have plenty in the port the coming and
ready to be sold already
thank you question for me you know
there's asked the last last application
it has it been any consultation between
parish council and the saying thank you
very much thank you we have the other
objector how it would who's who's a
neighbor
the middle button yes that's the one
thank you
yeah you have three minutes
Thank You chairman I'm Harriet wood and
I'm the lease holder of 19 cents Wiggins
Drive my property is situated in the
block of flats to the east of the
proposed development site as you will
have seen I made an objection to the
proposal during the consultation period
and raised concerns of the proposed
properties having an adverse effect on
my property I've prepared a few slides
with photos just to reiterate my point
this first slide is the view excuse me
the view from my side living-room window
which would be directly facing the
proposed houses the plans submitted for
the purpose of the application are
fairly misleading as the houses will
only be 4.5 metres away from my property
despite the plant showing the space
between the flats seeming much wider
than I'll stand close which will be a
minimum of 11 metres away the houses
will be extremely overbearing and all
the light into my side livingroom window
will be lost
Thank You Jonathan I've included these
pictures to try and help illustrate how
overbearing these properties will be and
again show the close proximity to my
property as you've just heard the post
Council have objected to this
application state in the houses will
dominate the skyline and be intrusive
and I hope these photos will help to
illustrate their point in the next slide
each resident in the flat has a private
fence garden which we each maintain it
is not merely a community amenity space
as is referred to in the committee
report the development is going to have
a detrimental impact on the privacy of
our gardens and whilst the appropriate
angles have been considered for the rear
windows our gardeners will be completely
overlooked - less than five meters away
the final pictures I've included just to
give the committee an idea of access to
the site and reiterate the points raised
regarding parking provision and access
within my written objection access to
the site during the weekend will be
extremely difficult if not impossible
for Morris as cars have to park on the
curbs around the road and this will need
to be carefully cuz
when imposing any conditions on the
development paragraph 59 of the National
Planning framework stipulates that homes
should be built where they are needed
making sure the needs of groups with
specific requirements are addressed
there is a vast amount of family
accommodation within the village already
with more currently being built this
quota is on target and these properties
are not going to have a significant
impact on targets being met I also wish
to reiterate the council's point of
objection in relation to the criteria
outlined in the core strategy at policy
15 and 16 under policy fit CS 15
development will take place on sites
identified within a neighborhood plan
Quinton has not yet agreed a
neighborhood plan and the resident
survey results in the twins
results produced in 2018 confirm the
parish Parish have met its share of
housing requirements for Stratford
district up to twenty thirty one I would
also draw the attention to the council's
five-year housing land supply
calculation which confirms the council
can demonstrate the equivalent of six
point two six years worth of housing
supply making this development
completely unnecessary it is for these
reasons I respectfully request that the
committee take these factors into
account when making a decision and
refused this planning application thank
you thank you very much indeed
any any questions councillor fielding
lorries going around there what's our E
that's referring to delivery of
materials at the site for actual access
to the site during the development by
mayor's looking at the photograph there
your flat is where that
councillor careful can we just go back
to the photographs from your garden and
could you explain those three separate
plots for the three different flats that
is my private garden and as you will see
on the right hand side photo you'll see
a very small fence at them at the back
and the upstairs directly above me that
is their garden and then the top floors
flat is to the right-hand side of the
middle floors garden so every everyone
is is privately fenced and that's that's
the point that you know we wanted to
make because it is referred to as
community amenity space and that is not
correct
Thank You councillor fielding you're
sitting with each block has a garden is
that because there are three each flat
is three storeys mezzanine one flat is
each on a floor I am just on the ground
floor then there is another flat that
identical to mine directly above and
then one on the third floor but the
space is for every flat there are
twenty-four flats in those four blocks
and every flat has added their own
separate private garden directly to the
left-hand side of that six-foot fence
that is look that is so my lip my side
living room window if we refer to the
right-hand photo is directly to my right
and I am looking out down to the back so
then if you have if you refer to the
middle photo you can see that the living
room window is on the left-hand side and
then the development is proposed on the
right Thank You counsel Dixon
sorry your side living room window is
that one of two windows serving that
room or is it the only window in that
room it is two there are two windows
there is one that looks directly out
into the front a sense within strive and
then that is the side window
thank you very much Andy thank you and
we have the agents Steve Bromley I think
you know the rules
I'm ready we're ready for you Thank You
Joan following an earlier withdrawn
scheme and discussions with the planning
officer the design has been amended and
the number of on-site parking spaces has
increased to satisfy the highway
authority the scheme before you
incorporates advice of the planning
officer and the Highway Authority we
also took into account the comments of
the parish council from the first
application and incorporated those
comments into the second application as
you can see from the committee report
both the planning officer and the
highway authority are now satisfied with
the development and raised no objection
we note the concerns of the parish
council over the height of the
development however the street scene
drawing if we could put that under we've
added over there streets in drawing
demonstrates building heights entirely
in keeping with neighboring properties
plot two and three on the right hand
side will be the same height as a
three-story flats alongside plot one
will be 8.5 meters high which is a
normal building height for a two-story
development there will be a significant
separation distance between the
development and 15 ales to enclose the
council's policy for the separation of
dwellings and the 45 25 degree tests in
Part F of the development requirements
SPD is designed to ensure development
has a satisfactory relationship with
neighboring properties but it will not
lead to loss of privacy the loss of
light or and overbearing effects the
development proposals comply with the
council's own policy as confirmed in the
offices report we note third-party
comments about parking for residents in
sense organs drive like many other
lockup guard sites in the district the
site was sold off my orbit housing
some time ago and is now in private
ownership and not available to local
residents for parking the Highway
Authority has stated they have no
objection to the proposals the proposes
offer development of a brownfield sites
in a sustainable location within the
confines of a local service village the
development is well designed and fully
complies with the council's planning
policies Chairman I ask that the
committee supports the opposite
recommendation and groans planning
permission thank you I think he was too
Romney you know any questions mr.
counselor pixon mr. Bromley presumably
you're obviously very familiar with that
drawing no doubt you produce it yourself
to the right hand side of the
three-story new proposal is that the
offense indicated there and would that
offense be drawn 1 meter from that
facing gable that indicates existing
fence is about 1 meter off the table of
the proposed development so is that
fence already there and is that the
border boundary of the plot sighs I
would I would say that's correct I think
that is the boundary of the sighs Thank
You councillor Barnes just checking that
the two-story element on the new it's
the same point as the adjoining houses
you'd be on the left-hand side of the
news it is a little bit higher than 15
Elston close but it would be 8.5 meters
high which as I say is is a typical
height of a two-story dwelling capsule
field you won't see the trees that are
shown on the next of the two-story the
comment was they were basically
fictitious in that they were not as part
of the true line of the fence what is
the distance between the end of the
house and the boundary fence there at
that point
chairman I think you've got asked the
officers I think we've done that point
of clarification I thank you
councilor kettle well again I think to
clarify that we need to look at the site
plan to see where that is positioned on
the side plan and the drawing that was
submitted and if we can zoom in on the
on that boundary you can see what space
is available I mean at the moment trees
it is shown or indicative we can plant
them wherever they can be planted so
that showed where hedgerow can go in and
trees in front of the development I
think you've got to accept the the tree
that you refer to on the previous
drawing is probably indicative again
through you and we're going to have to
go to the red line that's shown on the
drawing you'll probably have to blow it
up so we can see exactly where the
boundary is because of there is some
there is some discrepancies over the
boundaries in actual fact I'll stink
some believe has encroached on to this
site in the past but my client is not
it's not going to contest that as far as
I understand that's that's at the back
of the site where the boundary is quite
at the front it doesn't really clearly
show it does it thank you
it would be yes concerns from the parish
district council about the impact of
vehicles accessing the site to enable
this quite substantial dwelling two or
three drawings to build is possibly a
question of officers as to whether is a
construction management plan setting up
but how do you envisage that working do
you say we have submitted a construction
management plan this site lends itself
very well to having a hard surface area
to the front of the development where
vehicles can deliver they can then don't
have to sit in the public highway they
can go on to the site to unload and load
because it is actually a hard surface
already so they can use that for loading
and loading and turning around to come
out again other than that they're using
the public highway like everybody else
has a right to do thank you
as I've asked everybody have you made
any attempt to consult with the post
Council on the autonomous development we
didn't on the first application but we
listen very carefully to what they said
before putting in the second application
sometimes a strategy can be to submit a
planning application show due diligence
in looking at all the issues the first
application pushes out all the issues
and all the comments from those people
and then you could take them in so you
listen but didn't actually go in and
speak with anybody that's correct we
didn't thank you
thank you very much thanks for coming
good to see you we do have they will
remember here we don't know we doesn't
have the war member sorry don't know all
them so points of clarification panel
Kelso kettle three points I think have
come out of what we've heard one of
which is 45 25 degree issue
I wonder if Jerry you could throw some
light on to impact how close it is she's
also said that the property is any took
I think four and a half meters from her
own property what is the normal
separation distance parking all those
garages were designed for you've got
three questions thanks thank you sir so
if you look on page 26 of the reports
before you it does address issues raised
the neighbor miss is correct he would be
situated 4.5 meters away and I've stated
and we did say in the update sheet the
the council it wouldn't meet the
countess was 45 20 to 5 degree test
however and the development quirements
SPD because it's a solid facing window
and the primary window to the living
room is on the principle elevation they
don't afford the same protection we'll
wait that's what you see many
developments are side by side it's the
way it is and for that reason
it doesn't have the same reason also we
then how to look the assessment so I'll
show you the side elevations so in
cornice again with the council's
development columns SPD these windows
which would be facing onto the rare
gardens and possibly overlooking are
going to be obstacle guys because they
are going in to the bathrooms and
ensuite sir so for that reason and then
Gordon sir development corners that's
the date under my assessment although
yes he is only four point five meters
way easier than the 45 degree days
because it is a side facing window not
the problem your window it doesn't carry
the same amount away he afforded to it
was the principal window and your second
question my second question I know the
orbit of solely these guarantees our
thoughts and what were carriage is not a
vacant space but it's Gary designed for
residents on the state to be able to
park are we convinced that there is
adequate on street parking for the
existing residents if this area you know
the parking is lost in this area and all
we have sold it but but we still have a
planning responsibility regardless of
the owners it's his pomposity
application is it I mean
you're quite right I was built a lot of
these were built at a time when people
would fill them with their cars but as
time has gone on the evidence I've seen
is that they get used a lot less now
people like to park close to where their
house is
we don't know exactly what level of
usage is but I suspect it was fairly low
and for some time now they've been
demolished in the site fenced off the
important thing is that the county
highway authority looked at this and
they've got no objection the other thing
I would say in terms of parking there
are other areas of parking to the front
a small area and then a larger parking
court here to serve the flats you'll
note that the other properties on the
road have got off street parking of
their own therefore his offices we're
satisfied that there's adequate off
street parking and if there is on street
parking it doesn't present a highway
danger because it's a cul-de-sac and
speeds are low yeah I mean all we do
have a habit selling they can't use up
though don't they for councillor bonds
are we in a position that the parking
situation he's okay yes can't our
authority are happy with it and as
offices we've independently reviewed
that response and we're happy with it -
based on what we've seen council site
boundaries it appears to be but in
relation to that drawing which I think
well my colleagues on the other side
referred to that tree not being
realistic where is the battery on this
site in between number 15 on the well I
can't comment on ownership different
dispute the red line boundary in front
of you in Scottish ministry as part of
this application
what does to it along with there's been
submitted past application the other
issue is as well if you look on to
report so let me try and probably got
one's best indicative
we've done the measurements to see the
descriptors by which the state has any
impact on neighboring the means is as
well as impact on landscape in the area
I have stated in the penultimate
paragraph on page 25 that number 15 is
Gary's is situated between the proposed
Berlin to an overall separation distance
of 10 to 11 meters solid by side
moreover the actual dwelling would be
situate 18 metres away from free story
element so as mr. Baum knees point out
the tree and all likely is indicative
I cannot disagree over that but as you
can see there especially with separation
distances and the red line my injury is
considered to be an audit requirement
and separation distances are in garden
development of quantum Cespedes children
the mean tea space it was referred to
that the officers described the area
behind the three-story flats as being a
shared of energy space
I think the resident has demonstrated
that as far as she's concerned it is
first off as private private space
relating to each separate property and
if we look at that I don't know 1921
I wrote identify how the amenities but
how they private gardens work and
therefore how should we look at the
impact of this development particularly
on the bait
once again in my assessment I couldn't
be a hundred specially because their
apartments I couldn't be a hundred
sensual what the boundaries would be a
lot of that would have been done either
through legal agreements of register and
so forth and we didn't have access
certain things so the assessment was
undertaken this community space but
still the asylum assessment as if it was
probably residential garden that doesn't
change the impact on neighbor and I mean
is has been taken under the fact that is
private community garden fair enough
it's now private ownership gardens but
it's still the same assessment regarding
separation distances amenity values and
what overlooking distance is and so
forth it's simply the fact that I was
referred to as community meanings but
it's because I couldn't be a hundred
seneschal which garden related to which
flat okay but it is whichever God is
which fact doesn't really matter whoever
has the closest garden to the new
properties whether it's a top plat for
the bottom flat the lady I suggested
it's a bottom flat what would be the how
should we assess the impact on that
specific God he's exactly the same as
I've stated in the before an impact on a
man I mean is it wouldn't it wouldn't
change it still if it was a community
aspect so let's say that that was as it
was for all the flats it was just open
community it's still a community
residential garden and it's the same
impact on development so under impact on
neighboring I mean is what I've gone
into criteria regarding is only four
point five minutes away there is no
overlooking issues regardless of
obstacle glaze it and it still with the
exact same assessment nothing has
changed in my assessment I would also
point out it's you need to bear in mind
that they used to be a row of garages
full link to that would have caused some
loss of daylight to that area so now
you've got a different situation you've
got a shorter but taller building so
there's that comparison to make there to
joke oh my ass
the flats themselves to the right of the
picture there earlier the blocker you
said they they've put a side window that
would look on on to the on today's new
block of buildings so yeah but the
higher the let's say they say the second
say the second floor would that still
have a window it would but you've got to
take into consideration for the
development that's being proposed
because there is no monitors a little
bit because there is no windows on that
on these elevations it wouldn't cause
any dispute on so looking into their
area alright so they're no windows that
would look on directly on top on the
side because it's obstacle guys exactly
it you couldn't look into vice versa so
they can't look at iris go glaze onto
your partner blocks because there are
two guys you can't look into it it would
be we can put in the condition the
garden up there because it's the
bathroom windows yeah normally you
talking i'll show ladies sealed so it
can open more oven and have a fraction
so you talkin the exact requirements for
it's not very far thank you very much
any more question kept playing can we go
to the debate then panel who would like
to count the balance this is a green
field side Vampir I mean you see the
green was green and it's banned in the
respective lorries I can understand
where we are I just feel like I said to
the chairman the parish council its
masculine bulk is in my eyes a bit great
other than that there's been a lot of
thought going into
there is to be houses there like the
numbers we're up to 618 Quinton we're up
to a thousand Lila Martin well over the
quota there is a need for this type of
development although the parish plan
hasn't gone through but bungalows the
one thing that was needed which I need
support the previous application my
concern is that you know they've been a
bit greedy may not be a reason for usual
but it's my thoughts Thank You
councillor bars councillor careful it's
a brand for your site and therefore our
policy would direct us that something
needs to go here without without any
question about at all
[Music]
aah ten does require community support
what we haven't seen any attempt by the
developer he may have acknowledged as a
mr. Bromley have said that they've taken
note of the parish council comments but
it is really disappointing that's the
second application we've had tonight
where there's been no consultation with
existing residents with the existing
parrot council and it should be a
two-way flow not a not a one-way see you
know it seemed like refuted last time
building things this time which will
might affect it's quite easy to have a
conversation mr. Bromley I'm sure it's
an experience enough as a planner to
understand those issues so I think know
there are niggles about this and
therefore one wants to look at the yes
it's it's a site that needs developing
it's a brownfield site but then we have
the the impact it is considerable bulk
it may match the height of the current
building but that building was built in
a previous era and when looking at this
is a separate application by having a
split-level in a way it meets the
requirements to match up on the left
that JoJo's slide there it matches to a
certain extent with the building on the
left and therefore you can say step up
it matches the building on the right it
is still a thumping great block which
currently we've just heard low level
garages before so I'm I'm a bit stuck
we're having a debate I need some help
from my colleagues I'm a bit stuck as to
whether this is you know is overbearing
we're satisfied the parking works
construction management plan works the
design is a huge improvement on on the
existing blocks or about your current
building but it's not a thing in great
beauty and this does appear to be more
appealing but it is it is big and it
will have a you know whether whether we
like it or not it will it will have
quite significant like we've been told
doesn't meet forty five and twenty five
although it's a subsidiary bill window
compared to them one sitting on the
front us councillor Dixon point picked
up earlier on I'm in the middle Thank
You councillor kettle it's councillor
Dixon Thank You chairman perhaps I'll
officers can clarify are the only basis
whereby we can actually refuse because
of the number of applications properties
already approved can we refuse because
of the property mix can we refuse
because of the absence of consultation
if we can't refuse on any of those
grounds then I would propose we approve
the quick bodies you can't refuse on
lack of consultation you have to assess
the scheme on its own merits the
slightly longer answer regarding the
numbers is this Quinton the policy sir
should have no more than around twenty
five percent of four hundred and fifty
so that's one hundred and thirteen
rounded up it's currently had a hundred
and that includes commitment societies
that are currently being built
[Music]
the mix in terms of the housing mix we
wouldn't seek to what was we have a
housing mix policy we don't seek to
fight it's such a small level of
development because the percentages
start to fall down at that level it's
very hard to actually you could never
meet it because you couldn't have one in
each category for instance so we don't
apply it at this level but I would say
it's not you know they're not it's not a
big group of five beds a level of mix
Thank You Council hearings just looking
through a s10 I can't see there is a
reason there which is referred to on
page 26 it's not a small scale scheme in
the fact that it's fairly substantial a
small scale housing scheme including
redevelopment of buildings there's no
redevelopment of buildings cs9 and get
me fingers in the right place again
again if there's nothing distinctive
about what they're putting down here
what they're putting the proposal will
be of high-quality architectural design
the idea that it's not distinctive and
the layout of proposed will be easy to
navigate with buildings designed and
physicians to define and enhance the
hierarchy on the street they they are
rather shoehorned in in my view and I
just I'm afraid I find no merit in them
they are rather shoehorned into a small
gap
and they're too tall for the area and I
would like to refuse the officers
recommendation one other thing I do
dislike the fact that the Planning
Committee is being used as an MOT to
check and see what the architects change
when they are they they are refused they
ought to go to the parish council first
before using us as method of coming up
with a plan Thank You councillor Barnes
disappear we had a proposal happy I'm
quite happy just sick in that so we can
move forward my opinion on this it does
seem with something great block I know
you
we can't make a reason for refusing for
no consultation if it was they should
have been influenced all attention here
to speak with the residents and parish
council what their needs are we can't
refuse on that time I do understand that
but in saying that I do I can see that
way once a match up with a with a with
the apartments though over there already
I don't I don't if we can brief refusing
on bulk of mass I have to think of that
one for the moment I think are you
trying to interject council
okay carry on carry on are you not gonna
finish that laughing if we look at age
10 the instructor of paragraph minimize
impact from the occupiers and use of
existing properties in the area I think
what the the resident of either 19 or 20
or 21 whatever it is there is
significant impact on on her property
being right at the basement of that of
that block of three of the three
properties look at the cs9 Senate of
subparagraph 2 sensitive proposals
including Latin orientation we census
and setting existing built for
neighboring uses landscape character
which not the second element and to
popper at the site and locality
connective proposals will be what
integrated with existing built fall
enhancing that Street footpaths and
green infrastructure across the site I
think if we were trying to go for the
design this is too big and it is too
close to the existing property that
there is an opportunity with both CMS
nine and a s ten because of the impact
is having on the residence and being so
close to the other property we can't
consider alternatives I'm fully aware
but there is an opportunity to look at
this site and it may have been done in a
way that could be done differently which
might have had less impact on other
residents so I think there is an
opportunity to have a better design and
therefore I think actually what we have
said for donkey's years is we have
complained about the quality of design
which is a s sorry which is Co snowing
and it is one of our core strategy
policies if we're not comfortable
because we think the bulk is too great
then I think we have a policy here that
would give us an opportunity to refuse
it on on size grounds I mean having said
that's and
para bondrée they haven't got to the
full 130 113 houses but mr. Gardner and
I have argued in the past about whether
the numbers are restrictive on this
occasion but we do have a five-year
housing land supply albeit this is a
brownfield site it does need something
on it so I think I'm inclining from
hearing what my colleagues on the other
side of the table have said consider
this might just be a little bit too big
a little bit too overbearing
particularly as on the left-hand side we
have actually got quite small properties
or we've got two storey properties and
there is a the design is quite clever by
suggesting by dropping the roof level
but I think that just looked cockeyed
actually I think it looks sort of you
know decide to do what it is designed to
do which is demonstrate to us that it
meets the thing on one side but they've
got the bulk on the other it doesn't
look pretty do is a proposal view not
refuse do we have a second at sorry
where were we oh right so councillor
fielding and not always it counts our
bounds you secondly digit
we we got a number of proposals I second
the approval to move it forward so that
we could vote
we've never two proposals it's frozen
that councillor Dixon
I think the clarification may be that I
in my questioning for clarification to
the offices said if we can't refuse it
on this this or this then essentially I
would recommend approval I think that is
what counsel the plans might be
referring to thank you right we've got a
proposal for refusing a proposal to
support officers recommendation I think
it would be a weak refusal and the
reason I say that is because clearly the
applicants had regard to the fall of
neighboring buildings as you can see
that I understand the point that the
building's lopsided but that's simply a
function of the fact you've got two
storey one side and three storey another
and to be fair to then they have sought
to address that and it roughly follows
that the ridgelines you see with a small
step down and for that reason you could
refuse it um well I think you'd be
struggling to say it's out of keeping
with the character of the area because
the form follows the form we see on
either side in terms of over development
which seems to be the theme coming out
from some of the comments I've heard
from members that's a stronger reason
but I would still say it's relatively
weak when you look at the plot size
again it's no different in terms of the
amount of built form within its plot
than the amount of built form that you
see on neighboring plots so there are
two reasons there both of which are
relatively weak one is stronger than the
other
how many buildings have we got well we
got a split-level which is not actually
built into one single unit I would
suspect our historic that towns and
villages are full of them all
we don't know do we right so we have a
proposal to accept officers
recommendation a seconder for that
councillor Barnes to accept approve
variant ation kara votes on people on
members to vote on supporting the
officers recommendation against I have a
casting vote so I would say against the
officer recommendation so we need to
proposal we need reasons for going
against the officers recommendation know
what the same Richard that bulk of
masses is though is
a s9 refers to CH 9 sorry CS no my
apologies gives us the opportunity to go
against what the office is saying with
us attractiveness and sensitivity to
others and distinct I can't call it
distinct but it's within those are the
reasons within a s 9 so one two and
three an a s10 yes 10 we've got
community scale and overbearing slightly
different from design but by all means
you can have it if I just qualify what I
mean by being different from design
overbearing is a measure of how much
overshadowing or daylight effect there
is on neighboring properties either
their gardens or their windows so if if
members wish to go down that route I
would suggest it's a second reason for
refusal separate from design firstly
design is one specific specific issue
I'm really uncomfortable there's a huge
difference in a street scene where you
get historic buildings which have got
different profiles different angles
different roof angles different heights
from a different which may have been
built in a different area and we see
that in Stratford itself - a building
that's actually designed to fit in
between two different blocks are just
that great to me it's neither one from
the other it was a split between the two
has you know the low level house to
match up the 15 and a high level
to match up with 19 20 and 21 would be a
very different scenario but actually you
just got it
if Phil's really uncomfortably so I
think that's is one area I think the
overbearing issue is a separate point of
Richard again as pointed out that this
will be a significantly wider forum that
we've currently got in nineteen and the
rest of that existing apartment block
which is quite thin and this is a long a
much longer building going back and
therefore the bulk is going to be much
you know it's deeper far deeper than the
existing building so it doesn't match up
in that way as well so I think that's we
got your bearing impact on this to a s
10 their mailing for consultant it may
not be reason for refusal but this does
not have the support this application
does not have the support of the local
community and we've heard that we've had
no representative community coming in to
support it
the district councils against it the
parish councils against it the immediate
neighbor is not happy with it so as to
that I do not think we can get any
support of ayres 10 because it is not
something of a cheese community support
Thank You councillor members have talked
about overbearing I'm conscious you may
mean over development and that was the
point I made about the size of the
building on the plot have I read that
correctly because that that could be a
reason and I've heard that come up so
and that would be picked up by cs9
so what I've got is it's not been
sensitively designed with regard to
what's in the area and it's an over
development of that plot in terms of its
size both country to cs9 a s tends been
mentioned but is 10 has a list of
development that's acceptable in
principle and under B its small-scale
housing schemes including the
redevelopment of buildings within the
built-up area boundary of the local
service village or otherwise within the
physical
confines which is what Quentin is in
accordance with sir 15 and 16 and that's
Quinton that doesn't require any local
support there is local support required
under a but that's a separate caveat so
it falls squarely within B anyway so it
doesn't need local support so I'd
recommend against using a s10 in that
regard you could use a s10 in regard of
it's got a bullet pointed list of the
staff which talks about minimizing the
impact on the character of the local
landscape communities and environmental
features and you can make an argument
the surrounding buildings of those so we
could put a Estonian for that reason
existing properties in the area which is
also that what's the area of a a stenos
I was focusing on okay but that would be
a second reason for refusal because
that's that going back to the
neighborhood amenity point but thank you
Richard could we now have a proposer
a second death or refusal please
seconded
thank you very much thank you
would you like fun building agreeing to
uture will draft it up and yes thank you
very much think then take a vote now on
a refusal please this recommendation
vote against no thought for the
support the hot office we've had this
bet this vote already yeah yeah we've
done that so we've had four votes in
favor of refusing so how many votes
against refusing yeah now we're on a
second
whereas we've had the reasons yeah so
now we're voting to refuse that's been
proposed seconded so we're voting who
wants to refuse four so we've had four
votes in favor of refusing how many
votes how many people are against that
proposal to refuse just to be clear that
I do not think that these these refusal
grounds will stand up to a at appeal or
through they'd say four I I don't think
they worth supporting do I therefore
vote against yes
so then that is refused thank you thank
you
wow that was only lost the plot there
may I apologize to everybody about
coughing and spluttering ready to say
fever
thank you very much thank you I'll wait
till the to the hall is cleared of
people thank you
next application 19 oblique zero zero
eight three three oblique lut land
adjacent to Quinton house lower Quinton
and out by an application to erect or
one dwelling some massive exception
excess and landscape reserved Matthew
you're presenting the case officer yes
thank you chairman yeah this one is just
down the road from the other one you've
just dealt with so the application site
relates to land south of Quinton house
and a nursing home which is just about
here and it's also south of the
development of four houses which is just
north to the of the application site the
site itself is positioned close to the
western edge of the village of Quinton
there are a number of other the
developments going on and there's a
recent housing development just on that
past wetland there so the application
site is indicated by the black dot in
the center of the screen so the red line
there indicates the application site so
that the four houses that I refer to
just a second ago are currently being
about I think a nearing completion in
that parcel of land just there the the
green edge to that site and the wider
site includes
sorry indicates a number of tpo trees
there's a number of individual tpo trees
just to the north aside as well there's
there's a bit of an update which will
come on to at the end but there's a bit
of an update about the t case on in the
site there's no disturb buildings and
there's no conservation areas within the
time this is the this site in the
southern part the parcel land
and this is the wider sight - these are
the four houses that are currently being
built out each green sort of circle
there indicates existing trees on the
site home to the passive land itself
sort of relates to that southern part of
the site and the the access which is
proposed off the main road so the the
application site itself
sorry the application itself seeks
account line permission with access and
landscaping as detailed matters all
other matters are reserved so this plant
here is just indicative of the site
layout again the green trees is just a
zoomed in version the green trees are
existing and the black trees there are
proposed landscaping features there's a
new hedge as well along the western
boundary of the site just take you
through some views of the street scene
so this is looking back out west out of
the village of quince and the sites on
the right-hand side and the new housing
development sort of behind those trees
that's it looking at where the proposed
access is going to go again you can see
sort of beyond the the new housing
development of four hours is in Quintin
house the nursing home just in the
distance and again another another
street view from the street and then
this is looking back east into the
village with the application site on the
left-hand side and the proposed access
is kind of going where that haratz
fencing is okay so that there is an
update on the update sheet there's a
couple of clarification points in terms
of the principle of development and the
TP OS that are on the site some of the
trees have been removed and they were
approved under a TPO application and
there's also support from councillor
photos and here's even but he supports
the parish councils comments in
objecting to the application
so in summary the principle of a single
dwelling is acceptable on this site
because it falls within the physical
confines of low acquaintance the
landscaped character of the area would
be maintained by the retain trees and
hedges throughout and the planting of
new trees his therefore recommended that
the outline Planning Commission be
granted subject to the condition set out
in pages 36 and 37 of the agenda thank
you thanks Matthew we have our first
speaker again councillor screwed up
actually no you have three minutes sure
I want to show this one which is the
historic site before any houses were
built there because I want to do a bit
of background so in 2013 an application
was made four houses in the area and
district council refused it on the basis
of the loss of trees that went to appeal
and the house is being built now I bring
that up because there is one single site
I don't know why this is cutting in an
outlet rate there's one single site
partway through the planning report he
refers to an adjacent site having
history and this one not the whole thing
is a single site which went to planning
appeal and that appeal ruling actually
stated that the development hereby
permitted shall be limited to a maximum
of four dwellings so that's what the
inspector said the site if you look
historically at the site is the whole of
what you saw there not the bit that's
been coned off I want to stress that
because in taking in making that appeal
decision the residual view that would
exist on trees the residual or the lack
of loss of trees would be maintained and
that was a decision that was made in the
appeal so what I would say is that not
only do we ask for it to be refused
but a non-legal view says the decision
has already been made it was made
against the whole site which let me show
you so there's that's historic as well
and you think something similar and this
one is looking from within the site out
and in that appeal the inspector was
looking at there being substantial trees
still here residual and that the whole
site area was kept back to the whole lot
with four houses only I want to also
clarify you brought up the subject about
lsv one and it's hundred houses one
hundred and twelve point five Quintin
its 450 up to not more than 25 percent
is 112.5 and the whole of lsv one is had
already delivered 853 and those fingers
are based on 15 months ago they're not
necessarily current so the whole about
everyone has far exceeded this is a site
that should be returned to woodland
which is what I think the inspector
expected to be the case
thank you thank you very much Andy Thank
You councillor Fielding when you've got
your construction management plan and
everything put together was this area
proposed or accepted as being open space
for the the residents or was it isolated
within what you were doing what they
were doing for the four houses because
if it's open space then I would have
thought that the construction management
plan or winning plans right I don't
understand the question I know what a
construction management plan is what I
think it is which is about how people
build things so what I've what I'm
proposing is there was an original
application in 2013 the inspector made a
decision based on that as has given and
that there should be four houses within
the total site is the fact that an area
has been agreed and put to one side and
therefore it is not it's been part of I
suppose the 106 or what may be the
management that this is going to be kept
or vacant and become a community orchard
so I'm looking at green spaces is
something we're dealing in the
neighbourhood plan so we haven't looked
at this because of what's going on at
the moment but it might be proposed
within a number of green spaces that
we're coming up with
thank you very much any more questions
for counsel Spooner thank you very much
thank you
we have the radio best and gait planning
agent make sure you have three minutes
as well thank you your offices reporter
set out an assessment against the
planning policy and principle of
development is supported the site is
within the physical confines of a highly
sustainable local service village and
its context is a built-in street scene
with existing hedging across the front
of the site a new dwelling will sit
comfortably within the built form and
character at the street in respect to
the housing numbers in lower Quintin
we've already had a correction on the
offices report in that CS 16 would allow
for 113 dwellings being 25% to 450 not
the 90 dwellings referred to in the
report the latest monitoring monitoring
data shows 100 dwellings towards the
approximate 113 requirement as built
tour with planning permission but in any
event the wording of the policy means
that the figures are not maximums
they are indicative recognizing
constraints which apply to some
settlements and not others also a small
number of additional dwellings is not
sufficient to conflict with the
strategic objective of the policy which
is to disperse development in accordance
with the character and function of
sustainable locations across the
district
there are Quinten as a category one
local service village is highly
sustainable in respective in sufficient
detail as to what the dwelling will look
like which was one of the parish
councils concerns the application is
only an outline application with access
and landscaping included as an outline
it only deals with the principle of
development and as it accords with the
core strategy the principle is supported
the details of a dwelling are reserved
for a subsequent application on which
the parish or the neighbors and the
district council can comment landscaping
is part of the application an amended
plan shows mitigating measures and
announcement no trees or hedges are
being removed as a result of that
proposal the proposal includes new tree
and shrub planting to compensate for the
previous loss of trees and to increase
the density of the vegetation screen
along the road frontage species proposed
their indigenous Hazel Holly corn bean
lime and Scots pine although the matters
such as ecology and highways are
satisfied labour immunity can be
considered in more detail when the
details of the house unknown overall the
proposal is within the physical confines
of a highly sustainable category one
local service village and is in
accordance with the strategic objectives
of the core strategy the principle of
development is what is being considered
and it is supported in terms of the
appeal decision the context has changed
since the time of the appeal a number of
trees have been removed for sound dog or
a cultural reasons and I'm content to is
granted for that to happen so the
application should now be considered on
its merits thank you thank you very much
she's better thank you any questions
could you and you're keen to assurance
that there have only been 90 houses I
think 100 113 if we round up stands gate
syndrome remarkably experienced plenty
organizations how many properties do you
think of being
since those figures were published
relating to the year ending 31st March
2018 I in low acquaintance I'm certainly
not aware of any substantial schemes
there may have been one or two and I
tried to do a search before the
committee that couldn't actually find
any further permissions granted but in
any event the numbers are not fixed they
are not considered as a maximum they are
indicative figures and also as I've just
said granting planning permission for an
additional one Welling would not
conflict with the strategic objective
policy which is to sustainable locations
it is a guide well I'm not aware that
there is any phasing applied to the plan
the houses are to be provided within the
plan period and there is no reason why
permission shouldn't be granted at any
time thank you mrs. best any questions
more questions thank you very much
indeed
thank you
it's points of clarification Oh counsel
fielding can they give us some idea of
why this area was to be left out of the
four house development when it went to
appeal yeah Barry just one second oh
good about the thing back up on the
screen yesterday the original
application that was allowed on up here
at this site here was an outline
application so it only saw a line
permission for four dwellings which is
why there was a specific condition on
the consent that the inspector granted
restricting it to a maximum of four
books it was outlined but with the
matters reserved so so if the inspector
is only for the reason the inspector so
the only forms because they're only
applied for four and because it was an
outline it has to be up to four they
have to say how many that they could
have built two or three it was batters
but outline stage you have to say the
maximum number of dwellings in the build
they said four therefore the inspector
had to limit it to four so that no
reserve matter went over it he didn't
limit it for any other reason only
because that's what they applied for
cancer kettle but if I look at the red
line area for that appeal decision which
I think Matthew is nodding suggest he's
got it
perhaps we could put that on the screen
I don't know whether that's possible
yeah that's the same way diner as I've
got it actually includes this there we
are as father I can understand this plot
is immediately down from that little
square yeah it's that
and therefore we've already got we
fulfilled the direct that direct
inspectors criteria because there has
been a subsequent detailed detailed
application or reserved matters
application on this site so the island
for by the Parish Council is valid in
the husband of Appeal decision
application has been approved the
inspector has limited at four on the now
looking to increase that despite the
fact that we've already got significant
fulfilling of our tier one category
across the district we had now have a
five-year Lance by which we didn't then
[Music]
against a target of fourteen the hostile
14600 so we need to answer to your first
point about the the four on the original
permission yes this is part of that site
and that's the reason they need planning
permission now if they'd been for five
third they'd have done a reserved
matters for five and we wouldn't have
what's in front of you tonight
so the impact of what that inspected it
just simply means you've got a new
scheme in front of you tonight which you
have to assess on its own merit the
second point about the lsv numbers as
we've heard it's a hundred in Quinton as
of last March we we've checked all
permission since then and have been no
more so it remains it a hundred so
that's well within that limit
no more than around 113 all LS fees are
higher as a group than the 415 it's at
853 but on its own that would be a very
weak reason to object to it because
Quintin itself is still well within its
notional figure counselor fielding the
back to is there any form of management
plan for keeping the grass and
everything else which the contractor has
signed up to because this is an
important part of the green space of the
village I would have thought that they
had a management plan in place because
we've already got one in another village
I know of with the same organization to
protect an area of land in terms of
ongoing maintenance it will obviously
fall to the the future landowner to
maintain there was nothing in terms of
the application as far as I'm aware that
detailed what the future ongoing
maintenance would would be at that site
the existing green trees remain part of
that TPO group of trees for the whole of
the site so any future works will be
submitted at EPA application but again
it would fall onto the future landowner
to carry out those works thanks Matthew
thank you just how many trees are gonna
be retained here
yes so every tree that's currently on
the site will be retained so the no
trees are coming out there were some
tree as per the update sheet there were
some trees that were removed under an 18
TPO application we we granted them to be
removed so I think there's about six on
that list and they're essentially
replaced by the the ten ohms at the
front of the site there so the types of
trees that have come out as part of that
CPR application are almost going back in
like for like at the front of the site
do we know at this stage whether that
that screening of it will stay the early
from the from the road and maybe looking
on to it was like quite dense so with
that today it's planning on staying so
so that the green again are the ones
that are being retained and that's being
sort of enhanced by the the replacement
trees that are going on are the front of
that side Tony you and don't mean no
cannot see cattle
any specters report recently refers to
retaining the buffer between the the
woodland buffer between the road and the
development and it seems to me that one
has to take regard to the inspectors
words they are experienced planners the
only place where there is a buffer
between the four has the top which we
can see sketch there and Road is this
plot so presumably the inspector
considered that the buffer had
considerable environmental value to this
site within law Quinton can you just
clarify the question perhaps perhaps
officers might like to comment on
therefore where we you know the
inspectors views on that buffer being
important to be retained at that stage
absolutely and we've taken that into
account and we consider that what you
see there would be a sufficient buffer
the photos you've seen make it virtually
invisible when the leaves on the trees
to see through it and that would be
supplemented by five additional trees
and we consider that meets through what
the inspectors thoughts were in terms of
maintaining a buffer thank you the the
building I no tenían outlined but can we
impose a limit of how big a building
goes there
Shawna's is now essentially scales not
one of the matters that they've applied
for yeah I don't have that document in
front of me at the moment the the trees
that are on the side of the moment are
the ones that are retained we've granted
the removal of some of the trees where
the house is going and one was done
damage one when Ida sees that they're
the ones that are updated on your update
she said this proposal doesn't require
any tree removal so this has actually
replaced some of the existing trees that
were taken over doesn't mean trees in
the garden with the house with a few
trees where is the woman what to say
it's in the same way that this
application would supersede that the the
for limit on the old application it
would also supersede the requirement for
a woodland management plan insofar as it
relates to this part of the sites at the
site they'd read now would become a
private garden and there will be no
woodland run it there would be no
woodland management plan I accept that
completely Richard because you're
converting what is woodland into a into
a domestic curtilage but an inspector
has specifically raised the issue the
importance of retaining woodland and
we're now saying actually the inspector
the fitness of you can be can be set
aside because we're gonna put a house in
an area which he wanted a little month
plan put together for
which have been answered that and then
we go on to give a each other
yeah that's effective what we've been
asked to do you've got to decide whether
there's any planning harm resulting from
the way they've put this forward it
clearly isn't as big a buffer as the
inspector who's envisaged but that
doesn't make it unacceptable thank you
right I think we go into the debate now
to start on the debate anybody want to
stop it's a sustainable site it's got
good access onto onto a main road we've
heard that
quinton is below a hundred and twelve
limit so there are lots of reasons to
support this application had it not been
in a wood which the parish has raised
has been quite key on which an inspector
has specifically identified and we did
hear earlier on that the inspector
limited he didn't have to limit the
application before he could have left it
vacant in terms of the number of
properties because I think that an
original outline application I think I
think the the outline application sought
permission ritual of one yeah sort for
four dwellings which is the intent of
that condition but he could have the
inspector would have had the wherewithal
to allow the appeal to go through
without limiting the number of
properties to fall no you have to do it
to define the terms of the permission
because the description of development
is four houses so you need a condition
to define that so you don't get a
reserve matters of more
okay think I think my principle is still
they wanted to with that thanks counsel
fielding I think we've heard from the
chairman of the parish council that the
neighborhood plan although is it
approved yet this this was again they
need greenfield areas and a woodland
site that was put to one side by the
inspector I think should be sacrosanct
and therefore kept in line with what the
AV inspector said and be the management
plan that we need to come forward and
I'm surprised that the developers
haven't put that management plan in
place if they had would that we have
that wait to prevent them doing what
they're doing
do we have a proposal to support this
application yes we have Tony you support
this application do we have a seconder
looking free you're looking very stern
there counselor cattle scraps dangerous
your secretaries right thank you
right we have a support there and we
have a seconder do we we have a vote on
on supporting this application raise
your hands fortune station so we will
say this application is granted thank
you thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen I don't have any other
business this evening thank you for
attending we've been here a very long
time any urgent business are definitely
is any urgent business and I have my
work thank you thank you very much thank
you